la production des 205 bloqué à mulhouse
le conflit chez peugeot et d'autres
informations plus breizh avec anne
ponsinet
production paralysé à peugeot mulhouse
la dernière chaîne encore en
fonctionnement bloqué et occupé depuis
ce matin la cfdt réclame aujourd'hui 500
francs d'augmentation du salaire mensuel
de base
en revanche dans l' usine de sochaux
situation plus calme la production était
normal ce matin
civ rocher inculpé démissionne de ses
mandats d'élus locaux ici en mars
dernier l'industriel avait fait
descendre dans la rue dix mille
habitants du morbihan pour le soutenir
contre la bnp
la banque qui lui aurait revendu lusine
petit bateau sans lui dire qu'elle est
faite en difficulté suite à cette
manifestation la banque avait forcé
plainte pour chantage et extorsion de
fonds
michel villemin le frère de jean marie
villemin aurait subi filière atteste
graphologique lors de son interrogatoire
à la gendarmerie de bruyère réaction
aujourd'hui de monique d'une main
grand-mère de grégory et je pense que
henry qui te donne une grande valeur
pour moi j'ai confiance nous avons
confiance à lui et il faut concerter
et si on se parlait titre d'un
documentaire sur les relations
police-population présenté aujourd'hui
par le ministre de l'intérieur pierre
joxe
ce film retrace une expérience de
dialogue entre police et population les
services de police urbaine le verrons
prochainement organisée à leur tour de
celle d'expérience
deux façons de fêter aujourd'hui le 16e
anniversaire du coup d'état militaire au
chili en septembre 73 officiellement
discours et larmes de réembauche sous
pinochet
le général averti que même après son
retrait du pouvoir en mars prochain
il ne permettra pas un retour au pouvoir
d'une politique démagogique et
officieusement recueillement et
arrestations par dizaines pour les
manifestants venus rendre hommage aux
victimes du coup d'état
statu quo à la bourse de paris
l'indicateur de tendance en légère
hausse +0 08 %
le dollar perd 0 65% ainsi franc 67 65